we are at the premiere for your film you
have seven grammy nominations tied with
billy eilish and you are performing at
the grammys and your parents when you
were little i heard used to take you and
you'd stand outside the staples center
i mean wow how does all that feel and
what would you tell that little girl
about all that's happening now oh my
gosh it feels so exciting like you said
i've like dreamed about the grammys
since i was a little girl oh my gosh
they're like singing song which is so
cute um uh
but yeah it's so exciting and i'm so
excited for the day and i've just been a
fan of it forever and so it's just gonna
be so exciting to go there in the flesh
we are here again at the premiere of
your film driving home to you which is
so cool and you know you talk about how
sour was all about the the heartbreak
that kept on giving and i know of course
you used your music and gave us all the
incredible songs that you did but what
were some of the other things you did to
push through that heartbreak and what
advice do you give people who are going
through it oh my gosh that's a great
question um
i think
prioritizing your friends and especially
like female friendships for me was super
helpful and that kind of love and
support is just uh so incredible i think
more fulfilling than any like kind of
like boyfriend relationship in my life
so that was really helpful well in the
film we get an amazing moment we get to
see you like starting to sing driver's
license for the first time and i think
our eagle ears caught that originally it
wasn't blonde girl it was brunette girl
why the lyric change you know actually
the lyric change was actually dan's idea
who was uh my producer and he was like
well you're brunette like it'd be more
different if it was a blonde lyric so
that's how it came to be yeah but many
changes were made and here we are and
they were all good changes um we also
wanted to ask you about uh you know the
next album because sauer again i gotta
read this all these facts to get them
right on track to become the first album
in history to have every song go
platinum or higher
what does that mean for the next album
where do you want to go from here oh my
gosh you know i just i'm gonna keep
writing about my life and writing from
my heart and
anything else that happens is just icing
on the cake i'm just so happy that i get
to do this for a living they're chanting
your name right now oh i know that's so
crazy
um we also wanted to ask about i think
your gloves might be covering it but you
just got a tattoo
don't tell my parents
no i got a tattoo with my best friend
iris on uh like the tip of my finger and
i was like if it's on the tip of my
finger it's gonna rub off in the air so
it's fine but uh yeah i did what was the
uh the motivation behind that and what
did it mean to get them together you
know i've always wanted to do a matching
tattoo with irish we've talked about it
for years and like a few days ago we're
like this is the day it's happening and
i love her very much so i'm really happy
to have a tattoo with her i'm gonna let
you get inside but our last question uh
billy eilish i know she's been someone
so incredible in your life and she said
something about kind of she wanted to
keep you in a glass box and protect you
what has her friendship meant to you and
what does it mean to be nominated at the
grammys together now oh my gosh i just
think she's incredible it's so cool to
be able to look up to someone like her i
just really admire how uh how confident
she is and how she just like beats
marches to the beat of her own drama and
i i think she thinks she's incredible so
yeah that's really sweet that she said
that